[Musique]
ça y est on est en direct quelqu'un peut
me dire si on est à l'antenne ou pas
c'est la france d'affilée sur la tête de
ma mère une émission ça et c'est
jardiland et jean j'étais un gars
d'aider tout le monde a l'impression
d'être à 100 de repas on va tout de
suite savoir qui est le prochain éliminé
de koh lanta
[Rires]
j'ai tendu centrale donne 2 2 me de
planter du lierre la jarrie dans deux
minutes là je finis bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes à l'aéroport et bien sûr direct sur
le bonheur attachez vos ceintures
[Rires]
attachées sur sa masse au couvent a
rigolé sec
attention comme la pub par mon bios
je suis
voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai pas
compris pourquoi ils ont mis un espace
la voilà genre d'endroit qu'armand moi
je vais faire une interview dans les
fleurs je pense à comment je vais te
nationale et c'est l'interview fleury on
y va laisser partir on est avec clovis
cornillac connaissait plutôt tunique
rose vous entend pas aussi avancé
vous entendra que leur voix
[Musique]
j'ose encore en jeu
chaud chaud quelle ambiance de groupe
les mecs
waouh j'adore c'est connu j'ai
l'impression
j'ai pas si les plus jeunes l'on garde
il est bien connu on a besoin d'avoir un
petit luxe qui m'arrive est là salut à
tous c'est le starnaute squeeze bien
entendu on va jouer avec une star dans
la nation on aura la star du moment
ringo ringo sera avec nous bien entendu
pour un live
nikos à 51 ans les loups j'essaie
cotonou les loups jeu pour le taulier je
suis le taulier on va recevoir les
tauliers soit
ouais j'ai fait que je suis fut la muse
et c'est pas pour vous moi déclare
manière touchante orias des photos rien
su dans la danse style et ouais je sais
pas où ils ont trouvé cette musique je
veux tout ça je suis racho touche-à-tout
achète on a thing un point bas du jour
voici l'image du jour voici clim
[Musique]
c'est un truc de ouf menace est bien
réelle et il était bien ce jingle région
[Rires]
je me barre de cette émission par onze
par baron je me barre et je suis obligée
de rester parce que je sais pas sortir
j'étais à deux doigts de me paraît
j'étais à deux doigts de me barrer
encore pu comme ça
[Musique]